you
[Music]
thank you all for coming for today's
distinguished lecture it is a week of
attrition since triple ayah is happening
at the same time wisdom is happening at
the same time
Eric Hobbit's is at triple-a I Susan to
me is a wisdom Harry Shum is at wisdom
so yeah it's it's awesome that whoever
else is in building 91 has come on down
are there any announcements before we
get started okay so so privileged to
host avatar doors for the distinguished
exit today ever as a professor at
Cornell and she was chair at 2010 I
remember for sure and she's won so many
awards
I noticed the bio is not yet up today so
she was one things like the full cousin
prize the godel price but the EA TCS is
not yet up on the website or it's not
showing up on the bio she yeah she won
EA TCS last year and she's done
foundational work in algorithms most
famous for network flow I I know the
first computer textbook I picked up was
Kleinberg and that was the first time I
actually saw algorithms named after
people and things like that you know
there was like treasure and there was
Lewis number and there was the Tosh
function and I was like no I'm gonna go
to AI instead but uh it's it's been
amazing to see and also the first book I
picked up in grad school was algorithmic
game theory so she's played a
foundational role in that field yeah
contributions are too numerous to list
but one thing I did realize in reading
through her bio is it's definitely
incomplete because it does not make any
mention of her unwavering effort at
diversity and inclusion and stem
outreach and things like that I think
the first email I got from you was the
expanding your horizons email
encouraging grad students to go and
teach girls and middle schools and
things like that so yeah it's it's honor
to have ever come
I'll hand it over thank you very much
thank you of the attendee thank you all
for coming and I hope you find the
discussion interesting I guess one
comment on a date summary you know I
hope you guys all do diversity in
improving diversity and outreach I think
there's a lot we all collectively can do
I do not keep this kind of things on my
CV because I guess I'm thinking of my CV
as a sort of professional sort of my
science contributions it's not because I
don't think these are important I think
they're very important and I hope you
guys all do this in particular
especially I mean the people who are not
minority and women this thank you this
is a ever twee should all participate in
especially the white the Dean on
minorities and I hope you guys care
anyway but I will limit my discussion to
two to the particular topic so the thing
I want to talk to you talk about today
is I think about learning in the context
of game theory and I guess it's really
sort of becoming kind of two parts are
people learning in a setting where there
is games and if I can assume that
they're learning what kind of things can
I say about what happens in games if
people were nice enough to actually play
in this relatively wise manner where I
have to be careful on what I really mean
whether it's wise to learn or not and
that's what I'm going to really stack
this so that's the efficiency part is
what can I say about the outcome of game
or efficiency of outcome part and then
the first part is learning in game so
what do I mean by games unfortunately I
thought I had a forward
but I mean is a game of some sort where
some players which in depends on the
application that particular player can
be either the the the people driving
cars or it could be a you know rewrite
their starting traffic some algorithm
because we can be a human or an
algorithm is making decisions as you go
one decision at a time trying to
repeatedly optimize some objective
function to make it more mathematical I
will assume that a couple of things that
are written on this slide the example
here is a congestion game so I guess the
assumption of Pi but a car soap racket
try to follow shortest path they try to
figure out where they get to destination
of the fastest of course it's the game
congestion your your speed depends on
who else is going on the same path
whether you carry traffic but there is
an implicit assumption in here is that
you're not trying to hurt other people
they're not you know your goal isn't
that other people don't get to their
destination you just want to get to your
destination and then I guess one part
that you're coming certainly in our
results or I think what's important to
think about in the context of of games I
think I'm giving up on this is that the
traffic isn't as stable necessarily as
you can hope
depending on whether the Super Bowl
ended or some news item van and the New
York New York New York Times website or
whatever happened traffic does change
and so as you are a rat or even
optimally sent traffic you're going to
have to learn or adjust to changing
environment and that's going to be an
important feature as I get later into
the talk I've you alternate between
using traffic routing and my
polar actually using action as my
example where action I'm thinking of
mostly advertisement auction I need to
think of a set up order that's where
learning will be relevant where we're
repeating a game such as the
advertisement auction or such as traffic
writing where the in the individual
outcomes in a game are not very
important like in ad ad auctions a
particular value of one ad it's a tiny
fraction of a cent in traffic rutting
corrupting there my not apply so well
but certainly in packet traffic if one
packet goes bad the internet drop signal
tries it again not that big a deal if a
host she lost a ketose back that's kind
of a problem that's a big problem
similarly in ad auction if you whole
campaign thanks that's a problem if one
ad didn't work out oh well when it
doesn't matter so that's the kind of
setup we're learning you make a lot of
sense and here again the advertiser is
not very fast but can leave and join the
system and there is an ecosystem where
things can change as we go so to make it
slightly mathematical I guess the game
will be that there are actions that
people can take put up ads choose a raft
to drive and then something happens and
you repeat the section over time and the
assumptions are players somehow take the
path data and figure out from the path
data what the hell to do next
so that's the model of learning I assume
that the goal is that they try to an
average - well again not very sensitive
to outliers but most of the time should
do well and that's because a small value
at each small value your cost in each
period so exploration is a good way to
figure out what the hell to do and again
the idea would be that in the beginning
they don't know what's up and then later
on they know so I guess that's sort of
the main topic of these sort of repeated
games and whatever happens in repeated
games and I want to start with something
which given that this is the iconic view
maybe I shouldn't spend too much time on
but other what else you know why why do
we want to do learning and what might be
the goal of learning and when we start
with actually learning and games was a
topic combination that we've earned the
first start economists started it before
AI was really such a dominant field so
they were asking this question and not
the question that I might want to ask
they asked this question or learning is
cool because players might learn to find
the Nash equilibria you just figure out
what might of the learning is they
weren't actually thinking of the kind of
game I was thinking of which which we
naturally or have to play with more sex
they instead thinking of what they
called pre play so they were thinking of
there's a ginormous auction going on
think of the FCC spectrum auction that
just happened but before it happened for
the previous couple years there were all
kinds of training things going on to
train the auction heirs had to bid in
this game so they were thinking let's
think of this training as a learning if
you run the training before the real
action then the players might we are the
learning figure out what the Nash
equilibrium is and then when the real
action comes they can play the Nash
equilibrium
that was the goal so they were thinking
of learning just the way we're singing
of learning but they were hoping that
learning will find a Nash equilibrium
and that's basically was but they hope
then just to realize how early they
started robbing zone in 51 so the bad
fictitious play which apparently means
or means but it's said what I said
they're your best response to the past
history so you watch what happened in
the past you think of past history as a
sample distribution of what other people
are doing assuming they're going to
sample the very same distribution and
just best respond to that this is a sort
of Beijing style learning assumption
that the previous behavior is a patient
sample from something and you react to
that patient sample and that's the
that's what
Robinson was studying and she proved by
the way just because of a dates comment
she proved
Robbie's enormous
that this pre-play was hoping to learn
learn lead to an - and what was hoped
and that's what she was studying what
time does it get to nosh
and what do I mean by lift or inertia I
hope that maybe doesn't need a
definition either but just in case
oops what did I do but it means that
they will find a solution that's stable
stable in the following sense that
stable as a one-shot game if I take and
there is a slight awkwardness in
alternating between writing and auction
is my two examples then one is an
example of every minimizing the delays
some sort of cost the other one is an
example of everyone who maximized our
utilities when we want to minimize
delays then a good smash solution a this
is a vector with a I is the component
for player I then this is what it means
to be Nash for every player I if they
choose to do something else instead of
their own component X I a I they choose
something X instead they would have a
higher cost that is they don't wanna do
this other thing that's what it means to
me national annotation here is a - sorry
is an N minus 1 dimensional vector with
the ice component ice component missing
which got replaced by X and that's what
it means to be Nash and what they hoped
is somehow learning will either achieve
this one shot get Nash equilibria so
that would be an equilibrium relic
repeatedly play the same thing over and
over again or at least converge to it in
some sort of you know distance like
metric distance and I guess we would
call this as a no regret assumption and
the question was does fictitious the
fictitious way that is best responding
to the past history leads to Nash
equilibrium and an unfortunate answer is
mostly not but Robins own proved that
sometimes it does in 51 prove that it's
a two person - strategy each game than
it does kind of nice two by two game so
a rock-type
not sorry to buy two matching pennies
which is on top of it zero-sum it
doesn't have to be zero-sum any
two-person game or generic two-person
game actually you know algebraically
independent numbers or something then it
does and then in 61 ten years later
rock-paper-scissor that is any zero-sum
game two-person zero-sum game and it's
kind of over here like remember that
line is mostly not but sometimes it does
there have been other attempts in this
line of work
which I view not survey going on even
today where you you still the goal is to
find the Nash equilibrium and so they
come up this computer and weirder
definition of learning where really your
goal is to find a Nash equilibria and
not tomorrow natural behavior that's not
what I want to do so I stock fictitious
place a pretty reasonable model of what
people might be doing the more modern
things are not and I disagree with the
goal I also disagree with the goal of
finding their chakra Librium I don't
know why would we want or expect players
to find a Nash equilibrium but there are
lot of troubles visit one is there
multiple Nash's so why would I expect
them to find find one of them
it is a multiplayer game of the kind we
think about the internet many many
players
it's an incredible amount of knowledge
even to know who else is playing let
alone what the hell they're thinking and
then there is computational difficulties
something that's algorithmically hard to
find this sort of distributed learning
algorithm is not going to succeed in
finding it either but further you look
at behavior we know it's not happening
this is from Microsoft data which
because I don't work for Microsoft there
are some secrets on the screen of the
kind that I don't know the answer to
like the bits are normalized and I don't
know the key word but this is an this is
a advertisers seven they give word on
which I don't know how many some six or
seven people are advertising gone and
the
days of this seven days seven
consecutive days and this is what they
bids look like these are advertisers who
frequently change they build their ample
evidence that they must be using some
sort of online tools because they
changed a bit too often for a human
intervention they also these are people
have insanely high budgets which they
practically never hit so they really
using their budget that's some sort of
insurance and the thing they play this
is that number that you see on the
screen to me that those numbers
especially the red one or this guy here
or that guy here totally look like
gradient descent style algorithm every
now and then they adjust a little bit
like gradient descent would they
learning they trying to figure out what
to do so I don't want to all of these
people as explaining a Nash equilibrium
for many many reasons because learning
doesn't find the Nash because they don't
appear to be finding a Nash they're not
that stable instead what I want to think
of is repeated play where they
repeatedly experiment with with the
games now if you're really more econ
back rounded then you might tell me yes
yes yes of course they're not stable
because this is a repeated game they're
doing something much more complicated
defining a Nash equilibrium of the
repeated game which is a very very
complicated object and I think the
pictures are not suggesting that they're
doing that that would be sort of a
threats of the form that if I and the
data are advertising for the same
keyword I tell a did that look and even
they it's my turn you want to be zero
and obvious it's your turn you're
building zero and this way of
questioning was paying low and that
would be kind of cool there's no
evidence in the data that they're doing
this those are very very complicated and
I got they doing it alternately I can
claim that they repeatedly playing a VAR
shot game in which you would claim that
on this day that red player has a high
value that's why he was bidding high on
this
his value change to law was it doesn't
seem very likely so none of these seem
very viable assumptions instead I want
to assume that they learning and they're
doing something like no regret learning
or fictitious play and a couple of
slides here which I'm going to flip so
really fast given that this is the AI
audience and maybe this is something
that all of you know very well instead
of playing fictitious play which is a
deterministic strategy that is you
deterministically press respond to what
happened something that works much
better at least in analyzing and maybe
more likely something similar that they
doing is they're not quite best
responding deterministic doing something
similar to it
for example they randomized between some
relatively similar playoffs so a
fictitious play would tell you to choose
the best strategy the what scores often
smooth fictitious play put put put in a
normalization factor and somehow try to
within similar strategies increase the
entropy this is also the same as but
otherwise known as multi fricative
weights and has this very nice property
but called no regret or small regret
property remember and here is the
awkwardness which two utilities right
now Nash equilibrium would require
deleting this thing from the slide that
the utility of what they played is
better than a single best thing this
hindsight this thing here says that's
not true individually every single time
step so in Nash equilibrium something
like this and also should delete the Sam
server there it's not true every single
time step but if I add it up over time
then it's you know almost true almost
remaining there's a small regretted or
so let's try to analyze this is a little
bit better there is a fixed I can change
my strategies as often as I play every
every player is a lot to do this but
compared to a fixed relativist hindsight
your behavior should be reasonably good
that is the error this on which you
that would be better should be kind of
small and in particular that rule and
many other rules get to error than to
somehow rule tea and maybe hopefully
many of you know but this sort of nor
regret learning I guess if you don't let
me save one more sentence before I try
to put it in context but this means is
if there is a really good strategy
that's consistently good I'm asking
either find it sooner or later not too
fast not too slow
that is after not so much time or do
something better that is if I am driving
to work and I don't know the highway
numbers here so let's go California area
maybe you guys saw what those numbers if
it turns out that when I'm driving
driving in route 101 is ideal I don't
have to drive on 101 I can drive in 280
and alternate between things but if I'm
consistently worse than 101 and there is
this 101 it's so simple
I should just do it then I should be
should discovery this is what it's
asking and it's giving you a little
error because it might take you of us to
discover this fact which is of course
natural because you're learning from
past I tell me so that's what no regret
learning is and I guess a couple of
things about no regret learning again
maybe putting in context or where I'm
heading so the first thing I want to
tell you is maybe one slide of what game
theory tells you of why this might be a
nice thing but more importantly are
people doing this
is the data bestest act is this a
reasonable assumption would I recommend
people to do not regret learning so
asking is no regret learning a
behavioral assumption that I want to
assume do I want to recommend to people
is that how good is this and then I want
to also tell you a little bit of what
can I tell you about games if I can make
the assumption that people are doing no
regret not so actually maybe I should
cheat and flip through this and come
back to it later so right
start with is not regret learning an
assumption I want to make about the data
or do I like it so again the utility
terms I want to obstruct away from the
exact error term which was rooty not so
important whether it's Ruthie or
something else if I play it for capital
time T I've run the error to be kind of
small compared to T so the way I wrote
it right now is a more generous epsilon
times T a small fraction should come
from the error and as you know utility
is go time goes the toy utility of
gaming is growing growing this time this
is probably going this time thereby
should grow a little bit slower this
time if at all at least an epsilon
fraction now what are good things about
this assumption or you can do regret
learning there are many algorithms
multiplicative ate is one of them
they're million of them and if you don't
know enough of them go up or ask many of
the other people in the audience there
are million great algorithm is very
simple was the behavior to me this sort
of if there is a good strategy please
notice it it seems so natural that it's
even believable that humans can do this
not just algorithms very natural and one
thing that maybe you'll see at the end
is it's a very handy behavior model it's
such a nice equation or inequality I can
use it it's a nice assumption that I can
build a whole serial on the same way
Nash equilibrium was a beautiful
assumption and economies build a
beautiful theory on Nash equilibrium as
a behavioral assumption which sometimes
they questioning but nowadays whether
that's a reasonable assumption but there
is a beautiful Theory build on it
because it is such a nice equation the
same applies to this but I also should
confront it with data and the data is
the data set that I already showed you
one big advertisement data set it's
coming from I already showed you one
picture from it it's coming from a paper
that denis nikiforov and the vassilisa
carnies and maybe you have seen some of
this if Wassily talked about this but
let me remind you how that will be the
most dominant feature of the data set so
this is again advertisers that I can
think of as optimizing something they're
changing the attorney frequently okay
also can think of them as a single
parameter advertisers they budget is so
sky-high that that's not real data
insurance that's not a strategic
parameter is they bid that they're
changing all the time
and I look at they regret how much error
they have they regret now this is a plot
that you should definitely think about I
guess the blue bars are probably easier
to see so we regret relative to what
they gained did that make sense if you
grade $100 $1.00 reverse regret is
different than if you only gained $1.00
and you regret is $1.00 also so
normalizing to your gain to me makes
sense as a measure if I look at someone
out here that poor guy is doing horribly
this is the one dollar gain one dollar
regret okay one dollar gain 70 76 77
cents regret shitty if I look at someone
down here the guy is practically no
regret these people literally have no
regret and maybe a better way to put it
the plot is maybe broken these guys
could actually have negative regret that
is they could be doing better than no
regret which is possible because they
love to change they live they build all
the time and the rillette measure is
against the finger bid with I'm sorry so
these guys might actually have negative
regret here 30% of the bidders have
negative non positive regret so these
guys are doing very well I'm reasonably
happy and can say that these guys here
maybe I don't know how far I should go
maybe till here 40 50 % they doing
really well these guys are not now you
have to be a little careful here or I
should be a little careful I don't
actually know about this guy's value
sir I inferred the value from for this
plot so but I really know that these
guys are doing badly that's a fact no
matter what they value is they they
regret is close to 50% of the utility so
these guys are all doing very badly
these guys here might be doing well
reasonably well what does this tell me
it certainly doesn't tell me that the
literal no regret is a good assumption
there was only 30% of the people that
here and 70% have some regret and if I
think about it it may sir me makes me
decide that I've liked this alternate
version which I put here on the slide
and I guess we have a paper at a year
ago nibs working with this alternate
assumption which we called approximate
no regret instead of comparing utility
additively I said well you know a little
bit of error you can't be that sensitive
if you're living in 10% come on that
doesn't matter anymore so one way to
think about this comparison here if I
change my classically regret is an
additive measure
I just compare the difference between my
utility and the optimum utility that's
the top line and as I pointed out the
classical measure gives you a rooty
kinda regret after time T if I'm willing
to give you a little bit of
multiplicative error that is I willing
to give you a parameter epsilon and say
you know listen 10% I don't care so much
please make the additive error or much
as small as you can but I give you 10%
multiplicative error in addition then
you can significantly push down the
editing error in particular I can push
it down to a constant so this has all
kinds of advantages or come back to this
in a second but looking at the data I
think this actually probably a better
model that multiplicative regret like
giving you a little bit of error I the
data would suggest over 50% of the
participants have less than 10%
regret or varus if I have to go visit
all easy row there was practically no
one yeah
can't you say that like here people are
reaching something like correlated
equilibrium and this seems definition is
almost same as that right yes I'll come
back to this give me one second
going back to the games of the
connection to correlated equilibria I
want to spend one more slide on
negatives unlike the sort of the issue
is this a good assumption or not but
I'll come back to your point in one
second yes the answer is yes and I come
back to you in one second so I don't you
know these are all for correlate for
this is an assumption I can offer you
one more single for the assumption and
then I'm going to offer you the main
argument against it this is reacting to
and it asked me to sort of try to talk
about the general picture here this is
an assumption of theoreticians like I
like it too but to prompt discussion I
should be more honest that there is a
downside it's not clear how good this
assumption is yeah
the bar chart assured yeah and the
square root because you would normalize
that it's kind of hard to say you mean
the note if it is not 0 regret right so
you're out the square root it's hard to
say you know I should allow some kind of
square root e what would the situation
look so one may be actually coming even
harder coming more up from you actually
a best question that I don't know how to
ask on this data set is what honor
system what is the moment I'm looking at
this and I guess one thing we're looking
at which I can't show that I add but I
guess we we now have some some chart
like one some data set showing what
happened like I wanna distinguish
between this 50 percent versus that 50
percent 50 percent that I know for sure
has high regret according to what I'm
looking at what are they doing the next
7 days and my ingoing assumption which I
think the data shows is true that the
people who are
regret more drastically changed a bit on
the next seven days and people who I
think are doing okay
that is they to think they're having a
problem and so they're varying their
bits very widely and part of it is maybe
something changed and they just woke up
to it like this
this regret is a good assumption if you
think you're against the study yes study
distribution of some sort and if the
data if the best response changes you
should adjust and maybe for these guys
here something did change and BAE slowly
waking up to this and effectively they T
is smaller than these other guys t but I
don't actually know and I think this new
new data we're currently collecting or
more precisely they'll get back to
collect to dealing with after the EC
deadline will hopefully give a better
answer to discussion so there are a
couple other datasets other than my own
that I can rely on there is an error van
rossum 86 ran a lab experiment with two
person coordination game that I think
actually is pretty good support for this
I originally started to think about some
of the newer results I'm going to tell
you about listening to a talk at EC 14
about the love experiment was trying to
tell us that people are actually not no
regret learners and in fact that's what
that paper does it's a buyer and seller
seller game again it's a human subject
experiment the buyer and seller game
where only the seller is a human the
buyer is a automat the the game is that
the buyer has a random uniformly random
value between zero and ten you were you
were the seller you're the buyer you're
supposed to make him an offer no you're
the seller you're supposed to make him
an offer and if you make an offer below
his value he'll accept and otherwise he
doesn't
and what offer should you make and if
you do a little analysis you should
figure out what offer you should make
that's not that's not hard but most
people don't do this and especially if
they weren't taught that it's a uniform
distribution they would have to observe
that it was a uniform distribution they
instead make offers and see what happens
and a better model that fits their
behavior is an incredibly recency bias
version that is they don't best response
to past history they best respond to
what the hell happened in the last round
or last couple of friends report I don't
think they do that know they didn't know
they playing against the buck no I did
they say they saw their claim is to me
but it was a heavily recency bias they
they behavior short incredibly strong
recency bias and I'll come back to that
point in a minute but I think recency
bias is not crazy in a changing
environment recent experience is more
relevant than past one which i think is
fine and then there is a recent golly
Nissan experiment which actually played
this in particular adduction as a as a
human subject experiment and mostly they
recovered the values they noticed that
buyers that they gave are sellers that
they gave teeny teeny values on
experiments so small that they really
should have dropped that they should
lose all the time they behaved
irrationally so they didn't play no
regret wrong way I would explain this
that this this poor guys in a lab
experiment were forced to sit there for
you know however long the experiment was
and it's frustrating to keep losing they
were paid to sit there but still it's
frustrating to keep losing this doesn't
quite happen in real life because people
whose values too low for this can just
drop out and advertise as well so I
think that's less relevant
but to show to you that it's not as good
as I as I'm making that to be let me
actually give you what happens in a very
very simple two-person game which is
almost rock-paper-scissors so this is a
standard notation of rock paper scissor
this square unit tells you if scissor
press against rock then scissor loses $1
in and rock gains gains a dollar the
game I really want because remember I
already told you that zero-sum games
things work out ok it's not a zero-sum
game it's the rock paper scissor except
we go and do each plate at eight nine
dollars if we actually match as it turns
out this game has the very same Nash
equilibrium one-third one-third
one-third that is monstered at the time
we pay $18 to a date it's a good game
for a date so question I want to ask
what happens if I do learning in this
game and I'm even willing to get you
started off from the one-third one-third
equilibria and I want to actually depict
this in the 2d plane because your
strategy here is in the 2d plane because
probabilities should sum to 1 so this is
1 probability 1 or raw probability 1 on
paper probably run a scissor and
everything in between
that point here is the 1/3 1/3 1/3 and
let's assume you started off of Nash and
I start over - but I'm very bad at
randomizing as they are all of the rest
of us and editors are a little bit too
heavily play a paper and say I'm playing
against Nikhil
Nikhil's learning algorithm will
discover that I'm very heavily playing
paper and as a result he is playing
learning algorithm they're very pretty
have you paid the thing that beats paper
that's called scissor however than my
learning algorithm you discovered and
the cues learn you got algorithm always
the scissor to beat scissor I probably
should
prepay rock thank you very wrong and
what we're going to do is actually cycle
around like this and the dynamic we in
this 2d plane will come out to the
to a sort of cycling behavior on the
boundary on the plus part which is cool
and actually this is better than playing
the Nash better for the verse for a bit
better for the red for the two of us
because we're not paying the $9 to him
mesh would so we thank avoiding the
tiger now in an interesting way but in
particular if you're not paying the
Nash's you guys see and what we're
playing instead is a correlative mesh
the play does not converge what we're
doing is correlating or shared history
what we're doing is something of this
form we both learning so we both
satisfying this inequality that our cost
or utility cost is less than any other
cost model or a little bit of learning
error but we correlated we're not doing
it independently hence it's not a Nash
okay last slides on the model of
learning and remember the slide title is
negative things about learning so this
is kind of a nice property here is the
reason they're not doing it in order to
get no regret I have to randomize if I
were to be deterministic
Nikhil knowing my deterministic
algorithms would beat me every single
time we know what I do and would do the
up do the bidding thing I have to
randomize and if you look at those plots
I said they look like like ready and
descent which kind of they do but they
surely don't look like they're
randomizing they're not wiggling like
crazy the people are not randomizing so
that's a problem what I actually
recommend people this algorithm to do
this so this was the question are they
running no regrets algorithms and
actually no they're not running nor gate
algorithms because in algorithm to be no
regret you have to randomize and they're
clearly not randomizing
second question would I tell them that
hey guys you guys should run in order
get algorithm and honestly probably I
should not for many reasons one reason
is what do you mean no regret against
the fixed strategy you might do better
maybe you should try to do better and
what's first no regret is not that bad
it sort of adapts to other people
strategies but maybe I should do better
and actually they're not the
rock-paper-scissor example of us here
exactly to show this to you if instead
of automatically reacting to what Nikhil
is doing right now I know he's doing the
no regret algorithm I can predict what
he's going to do tomorrow I should react
to that instead that's a better move
than just reacting to his past I know
he's algorithm I should react to his
algorithm to his next step which I kind
of know yeah well yeah it will get
chaotic if people do this so I'm not so
sure I would react it but I want to make
a different point and that's my coming
back to being positive about no regret
learning I did not make the assumption
that they're running minor of that
algorithm which they clearly are not
I didn't recommend they running they no
regret algorithm I was asking can I mold
them as achieving no regret and it seems
like I can they can do better than
getting no regret and I would recommend
they do better than no regret but they
just seem to achieve a no regret like
condition is that necessarily running
the algorithm so what I'm gonna do in in
in in modeling this is not recommend
they run this algorithm but instead
model behavior with this condition which
is not the same assumption and I think a
much better assumption than the
recommendation that they they page okay
so I'm going to give you one other part
and I don't know how many minutes I have
for one other part but use a few some
amount of minutes one benefit of this
which I already mentioned in this one
state English
but I want to give you a little context
for it is that this neural net
assumption is such a clean beautiful
mathematical assumption it's so usable
and how many many things one can derive
from it and I would say someone trained
as a mathematician is that having a
clean mathematical model is definitely
good for thinking about what follows
from this assumption this is where I
want to go back to your point and
actually I don't know if I can go back
fast enough there is a slide that I
skipped in in the middle exactly this
one where I wanted to make exactly the
point that you asked me about if I take
the absolute limit where I regret went
down to the relative regret went down to
zero because
rooty that is grew less slow more slowly
than time then is absolutely no regret
the assumption here is was that the
utility of what they play if I take the
history of play as a empirical
distribution then that distribution will
have the nash like no regret property it
will have this property that the
expected utility expectation approved
from the history of player I is is
better than any fixed strategy with
hindsight this is called correlated
equilibrium it's like a Nash equilibrium
same inequality except that the player
correlated and the way they correlated
is that they both pulled from both based
a behavior on the same history and I got
them correlated as we saw in the example
and going back to where I was or if
we're doing things in the wrong order
so this says that they converging to or
getting close to a correlated
equilibrium we can ask a bunch of
interesting questions what can we say
about quality of a correlated
equilibrium and what can we say about
the speed at which they converge to this
correlated equilibrium and maybe one a
most fun of a most fun of and one most
emphasized is can we adjust this and the
answer is
we can even if I actually don't keep the
fit the game stable that is learning is
good because learners can adjust to a
changing environment if you're learning
you're not blindly playing a Nash
equilibrium and you know hoping for the
best that it stays the same game you're
watching what happens and if the
environment changes you will learn to
adjust that's what learning is good for
can we actually make this mathematically
precise and say learners adjust to the
environment and they constantly achiever
or over average time at g5i social offer
and the answer is yes and in the last
maybe a couple of minutes I want to give
you a sense of how the no no regret
learning actually gives you enough power
to prove this kind of things so
hopefully that's still okay so what is
the kind of thing I wanna prove this is
something that you often goes under the
name of Christ of energy and maybe one
nice simple example of myself and tim
roughgarden is for traffic rioting and
it said that if you take this traffic
rioting example then the cost of the
nash equilibrium is no worse than the
cost of an optimally designed strategy
where everybody sending twice as much
traffic you might say that that two over
there was not your favorite degradation
constant that you have to run this twice
as much traffic I want to point out that
this is as opposed to much much much
worse things like what's usually known
as the tragedy of the Commons where the
degradation has two big rates with more
participants the worse it gets
price of energy formally defined as
follows classically it's about Nash
equilibrium they take the utility of
Nash and compare it to the optimum then
in sequence of papers originally studied
by Blum and co-authors and then a very
nice paper with tim roughgarden got
generalized to learning outcomes what
they said is we repeat the same game
capital T times take the utilities of
the players and overtime and compare it
T times the optimum at that point the
game
and the prayers were stable so the
optimum didn't change and what I really
would like to do and this is the last
one is I want to keep changing the game
too so instead of having T times the
optimum down here I have to change it
some over the Optimum's of all those
games and that's what I really would
like to shoot for our actual mall goes
as follows it's a pop it's the same game
like we're still playing traffic rafting
every single step but players get
replaced and I guess we call this
dynamic population every iteration there
is a parameter which I can tell you a
little bit more about in a sec with some
probability P every player vanishes and
gets replaced v is an arbitrary new
player so what I mean here because every
player vanishes with some probability P
if there are players then a noticeable
fraction like PN of them lots of them
vanish every single step so something
changes all the time but because at the
end because of the changes arbitrary if
you stayed in the game you have to keep
watching the situation might change and
you have to keep learning but at the
same time because the only vanish is
probably the TP any particular player we
stay long enough that learning will be
viable and in particular I have to keep
them in long enough that in my Nordic
net learning assumption they regret
error will not dominate what they got
that is so that the regret or ghost goes
down to zero so I have to keep them
around long enough that in expectation
they regret that or goes down to zero
yeah things change dramatically if
players were getting replaced with
higher probability if they had already
incurred a very high regret so modeling
this idea of ruin really gambling when
you people who are who are currently
feeling like they're losing in this
marketplace they are the most likely to
leave no we would be very like as long
as as you know I it if
it helped me it's only one hurt
it's very tolerant of which fraction we
are very important if you not replace a
very big fraction at a time so that most
of the people can learn one way that the
results are not as good as can be is
that I'm only looking at social welfare
which means I'm averaging everyone's
behavior so there are there could be
people who are doing really really badly
and my average doesn't hurt because
there's so many of them and you're
actually helping in that category not
hurting so your way of replacing them
but only make it better problem I think
people would vanish have people leaving
because they're winning Yeah right dad
my dad I need to think about that might
actually hurt like that have to be
careful whether I can keep the result
that way but it is happening because
it's it making the the problematic
people go away good questions so we're
doing this in a class of games that team
called smooth games so actually I'm
using my version on actions I won't
spend a lot of time explaining what this
games are maybe I have one sentence
summary is and there will be two
sentence summary between two things one
sentence summary is that almost all the
price of energy with that are of this
form so actually that's the next
sentence so it's not here
I love this class but given that I
probably shouldn't keep talking for too
long I won't spend too much time
explaining what the class is I want to
tell you one line of height gets proven
which i think is important to sort of
think about what is there to prove so
all we have is the no regret assumption
and all these proofs need is so here
this guys in this particular example of
what it saying a sort of action game
that they want to win one of those color
strings and maybe they have different
values for different colors and they
bidding on one of them and that's a game
because you have to decide how much to
be then which one to be done and of
course as usual is any of these the best
action might depend on what the what the
hell the other guys are doing and but
the interesting thing in the proof that
in
to prove things I don't have to always
figure out what's best I don't have to
do what's best there is a particular
action that I should not regret is the
optimal solution so if my optimal thing
is to win that that's a read assignment
over here then toursad I should not
regret reading on that guy that is you
not asked to bid on that guy you're not
asked to know what that guy is but
you're not regretting anything in
particular you not regret that one
either and that's the only thing the
proof uses that is that there's one
thing the optimum should not regret that
behavior and that's the assumption that
the proof uses there are lots and lots
of papers that use this kind of proof
technique and I'm going to maybe go to
the skipping a couple things I might
come back to showing you the one
technical other thing I wanted to show
you but I want to do with this changing
population ideally I would like you to
do this not not just not regret the
optimum but not to get the optimum every
single step and that's actually went too
far even if I take one guy at the
optimum might drastically change just to
give you an example we're playing a
matching game here's the optimum one guy
left
of course the optimum change for
everyone's calls and are Manning Pass
and everything change but if you're low
careful you can design something and I'm
definitely cheating here called a stable
optimum that is a sequence of optimal
solutions that stay stable that is don't
change much or rarely change or any one
player change change very low I have two
techniques or we have two techniques to
generate such a thing
one is specialized two particular things
like matching for example the greedy
matching is much more stable than the
than the optimal matching so running a
greedy like system is better but maybe
an even better there's a whole technique
developed that they're called
differential privacy which since since
the artwork is a Microsoft person or
used to be a Microsoft person hopefully
you guys so know
differential privacy if you think of
what differential privacy is trying to
do hey it's the same thing it's a
different argument they want the
solution to be not sensitive to rather
one guy participates or not that's
literally what I wanted to for a
different reason so I can inherit the
whole differential privacy literature
and generate theorems of the form and
maybe that with many many of these games
we can have the price of an IV result
recovered even with changing population
I need to have the probability not go
below something like one in Lock P this
is because I want everyone to stay
around for at least lock P time that's
so that the regret error will not
dominate the behavior in my balance and
the balance I get is a product of three
parameters of course I lose the price of
energy band it's the same price of
anomie proof if there was a band there
I'm recovering kind of the same band I
have two losses both of which go to one
as things get better there's a regret
error trouble I have to accommodate a
regret or if the probability is is its
high then they don't stay long enough we
get there is relatively high as I keep
people around longer regret that all
goes to zero and the second is the how
much it cost me to have a stable
solution as the game gets bigger a
higher population as you might know from
Cynthia's work or Cynthia's work with
many other people the stable solution
get closer closer to optimum as it's a
large population game in a smaller
population it's harder to make it
differentially private
so again if the population is high and I
kept people around relatively long time
then I recovered the price of energy
band otherwise there is extra little bit
of degradation around and I guess I've
honest envious I hope with the beginning
I did convince you that that learning is
a actually good assumption it is not a
bad way to adopt it's much better than
Nash
if I play Nash against a bad opponent
and I will not
either that or Nikhil as playing the bad
solution if I play national paper
scissor no matter what the opponent does
I get zero as my payoff if the
opponent's playing badly I should beat
him so it's a better of a turd up to the
opponent no need for the common prior
and that was a teeny bit at the last ten
minutes I tried to convince you that
learning actually prepares do well in in
even dynamically changing environments
which i think is a nice feature but I
didn't do and at the slide I skipped
through in the middle is the open
question part and maybe I should end
with that is that I did criticize
learning for the kind of thing
Nikhil picked up on that I should
predict what they opponent does and
react to that there are a few papers
that trying to say things of what
happens when you do such a prediction at
the moment they always get beaten that
is they show something you could do with
such prediction and then say hey but
that's happening anyhow even if they're
not doing any prediction so at the
moment we're not aware even though
they're very attempts at this I'm not
aware of any papers that says something
better happens to either the players or
the game overall if political people
people play in a way that's more predict
the opponent but I think there is a path
there and there's something good should
happen it's clearly the right thing to
do and at the moment I can't prove
anything interesting so I'm going to
stop here stop here and thank you
[Applause]
if you go down that road of trying to
predict what the opponent is going to
play and how he's gonna respond to your
toy do that but you don't have some
mobile application time you have to
think about limited resources Ike's only
should I mean they are to attempts that
are out there were very much more
simplistic attempts what they say is any
of these no regrets learning algorithms
and multiplicative eight for example but
all of them they adjust the probability
distribution very slowly that's an
interesting fact all of this fact that
is know that the distribution today is
virtually the same as yesterday
and as a result runs something that they
called optimistic medicine optimistic
meaning that its recency bias that is
very heavily takes into account what you
did today and you prove syncs with that
that doesn't need like it's just
optimistic it doesn't need extra
computation it didn't do the game that
Nikhil was inducing me to think about
that if I'm going to take advantage of
what you're doing you should predict
what I'm doing is react to that you know
if we you just assumed that we're both
running this form of optimistic medicine
rather than having one of us run a best
response to the optimistic we were
different which is not it which is not
itself optimistic me or dissent so
you're right there is a computational
problem here once I take this today to
the proper level these papers do not at
the moment
like recently the poker Texas heads up
bigger the heads of poker thing was
solved by libera does at CMU and they
were essentially doing that kind of
reasoning and they essentially through
insane amounts of compute and the brute
force trying to reason through all steps
of bidding and betting
and I'm at the core it was a regret
matching algorithm but they had to
precisely think about like what would
the players best response speed of this
yeah actually points had that issue that
I swept under the rug despite other
issues that I focused on is that the
games I was playing here which is post
traffic rat again and this bidding in
adoptions are compared to poker they're
super simple game it's like you know
you're choosing a pass you're choosing a
beard and there's this multi-line games
such as even that particular simple
poker they're mostly round like the the
strategy space is much much more complex
I mean the the writing game which has a
many pass but you're still choosing
edges really it's a you know it's a
shortest path computation it's not
you're keeping parameters on the edges
that's very manageable
poker is a much much more complex game
and there is certainly a lot even
running this augur these algorithms I'm
talking about would be problematic in a
poker because there's so many different
strategies they doable in in in pass or
doable in low dimensional spaces that's
a higher dimensional space so there is a
computational problem there even with
these simple algorithms they don't is
something a bit more sophisticated but
that's the sophistication is more coming
in that they actually capable of running
this yeah so sorry if I missed this but
what information is the learning player
being given do they get to see all the
opponent's actions and utilities or is
that all in from them excellent question
definitely they don't see the opponent
action to get the actual balance to the
extent I've ever bounced at all on these
slides they get information of what
would have happened if they have done so
they need their is the what I often call
in learning a full information form
feedback that is you don't necessarily
know what the other guys are doing but
you know what would have happened have
you done that that is thinking of
traffic ratting you drive on a past
but for whatever reason you actually get
traffic reports from everywhere
including very over not actions I could
have taken I know what I know what
happened this is you know based on
traffic report may be reasonable and
traffic ratting I'm not so sure it's
reasonable and Internet traffic writing
but I guess they're doing pigs which
maybe can approximate this it is
actually quite reasonable in a deduction
because they the feed the the feedback
sync they're getting is giving them
payoff curves so they're getting this
this kind of like you guys that is your
company is offering this feedback to the
bidders so that doesn't say who the
opponent is they have to go on the web
if they're a pizza company honestly
probably all of you know the local pizza
names so they know who is advertising
for pizza but if not they have to figure
it out the way you do it go on the web
but they do get the counterfactual
factors as a form of feedback and that's
what this assumes as their bids like
drop below other people's bids so how
things are kind of suddenly changed what
they get us feedback is what would have
happened maybe not instantaneously but
aggregated over some period and honestly
I don't know the period lengths maybe
over the day or over like maybe some of
you know this here well I'd like that I
think I like it
burnt but I'm reacting to is you said
with the drops things are random enough
that there aren't that many drops I've
seen those curves they are pretty smooth
and because it's aggregated I think on a
day or an hour or something there's some
amount of aggregation of what they're
getting but your company as does Google
feeds back cursed curves like that and
that's what this results in it so the me
yes so the way the look of this social
behavior has people are doing this very
clear behavior so either the main
takeaways like it's like if they
converge compared to like we're doing
the best response and the Nash
equilibrium doesn't converge because the
price of Anarchy bounds if you make like
these games are smooth then they're hold
they would have weren't held it even for
pure
with them kind of thing so like what's
like what is this separates this is it
just the convergence that this modeling
explains that okay people converged
other like if the Nash equilibrium
wouldn't explain that okay why would
people who converge to Nashville so I
think of traffic routing then there to
sit there so traffic writing is one of
those games where best basements are
learning on a single game does converge
to Nash because it's a potential game so
they're the only class getting their
toothbrushes be getting at is the speed
of convergence that is what's a regret
error how fast early converging and
second and maybe that's the end and I
really read through it that I can switch
the player set that it it I'm switching
the player set so fast they me roughly
these end players I keep them around for
fun in log and time that is a almost a
constant fraction of players vanishes
every single pair of time steps there is
no way they're converging turning Nash
because the Nash keeps changing yet
they keep the social welfare high like I
said that I can do this they can't
convert soon as because the game isn't
stable enough F one player is around for
quite a while so he can do something but
the Nash moved around because I kept
deleting and adding players so they
can't possibly converge to the Nash
because there isn't such a thing as B
Nash every single step the Nash is
different and yet we can make statements
about refer about that somewhat is I
feel okay at least the way I look at it
is somewhat different right that's much
more like stability because like if a
game is smooth even if you don't
converge to exact Nash but you can
converge to approximate pass you will
still be good like the price of Anarchy
bond will still go through if you make
this assumption that game is a smooth
game so I actually like okay so in
writing indeed it would go to Nash and
would go to approximate match reasonably
fast yeah and the only plus here is I
can swap the players in a knot which I
think you you you need to prove to me
that the Nash moves slow enough I don't
think so but if you take action game
auction game is not a potential game so
there they're not converging to an ash
in fact there is no guaranteed a
converging period they can alternate the
way I showed you in the rock paper
scissor things never converged that's
not converging so when something is not
converging then this is a separate
statement and I guess one thing I didn't
emphasize but may be useful to say that
what this game does as I did kind of say
it converging to the set of correlated
equilibria now what do I mean
correlated equilibrium is a convex set
it turns out it's a convex set in a very
high dimensional space so when you
converge to a convex set or any set you
can do kind of two things you can
converge the point in that set and if
they were to do that which they do in
writing they do not do it in in in add
actions or in in item actions then they
sing they converse to is that is a real
Nash but they can converge to a set in a
different way here is my set and here is
high converse to it I get closer and
closer to the set maybe I never went
into it and I thirdly don't didn't
converge in the classical sense I just
converge to the set I'm really close to
set I'm circling around it that's not
happening in rock-paper-scissor
in that sense they didn't stabilize they
didn't converge but every set in this
whole correlated equilibrium the thing
they're getting close to has good social
effort there I prove there the system
proves something much stronger they're
not converging period-- and yet social
welfare is good so we don't know such
results for like Nash equilibrium saying
like you if it doesn't okay doesn't
maybe it doesn't even make sense why it
wouldn't make sense I feel like I don't
know such as that because they couldn't
be true there there's a little cheating
what I'm saying if if playing with
converse to Nash equilibrium I almost
would prove that finding a Nash
equilibrium is computational easy not
quite because I would say approximating
it easy and what we know right now is
finding
hard not that the proximity think is
hard that sort of under to believe that
this difference is minor and really
approximating it is also hard then that
things should not be true learning
should not converge to a Nash because
finding a Nash aside this is also tried
done on the item action game finding a
Nash is hard so they this method cannot
I I don't have an example to prove to
you that this doesn't converge tarnish
but I know it cannot because this is
do-over and that one's computationally
hard okay
[Applause]